ambition
greed
and a guy named willy
willie shakespeare
by the pricking of my thumbs
something wicked
this way comes
our version of macbeth made shakespeare
accessible
the way i've always looked at the film
is that it doesn't take place in any
physical place that takes place in the
minds of the characters in the
psychological reality macbeth has been
done in many forms and many time periods
but we were inspired by joel's vision
which was this highly defined black and
white and very geometric and very
architectural
and that's what helped us come up with a
set of rules on macbeth it was
fascinating i don't know i think it's
the first time i worked with a husband
and wife team
so that was that was interesting just
watching the two of them how they
operate they're two halves of the same
person i mean they rely on each other
and uh trust each other there's both
brilliant brilliant artists and care
about the work joel really wanted the
language to be very specific and very
clear and he really wanted the actors
and their ability to pull these scenes
off and make the language sing and make
it real at the same time if chance will
have me king why chance may crown me
without meister
come on come may it's important for joel
in films to usually establish visual
themes well verbal themes and auditory
themes he's just brilliant he's one of
the most if not the most brilliant
filmmaker i've worked with period there
are a lot of things about working with
joel that are
unique compared to working with other
filmmakers joel is known for really
preparing well for pretty much the whole
process he had this story and he had the
visuals already in his head
seeing how joel saw it was a master
class in filmmaking
[Music]
i had done a number of movies with joel
and ethan so i had a pretty good sense
of what kinds of actors he liked and at
this point we had frances mcdormand and
once you start thinking about who can
play opposite her and hold their own and
has had classical training
it was a very very short list
and then when denzel said he would do it
it was kind of a miracle because he's
classically trained and he's a huge
movie star
[Music]
i mean he's a giant so that was kind of
a dream come true duncan come see you
tonight
look like the innocent flower but be the
serpent under it leave all the rest to
me
she was amazing amazing
she's brilliant brilliant and a lovely
lovely woman lovely woman
there was no color on sets there was
only a dress or two that francis
mcdonald was wearing which were in color
but otherwise everything was black and
white so when the actors came and said
they were really aware of what it looks
like
all was in black and white
all on sound stages
it's just got these very exaggerated
abstractions sometimes that come from
the sets it was kind of obvious it has
to be black and white because
black and white already introduced some
kind of abstraction you see it's uh
you're not connected to reality in some
ways with black and white you have
already a distance
being so abstract i never felt the need
that i needed to have any muted color at
all and just to move quickly it was just
easier to paint in grays i've done
another black and white movie and for
hair what you want to do is you're not
dealing with color so you want to have
shadows
and reflection and those are your things
you're working with
light or dark shiny or not shiny
designing a film that's in black and
white was hugely important texture and
textiles and embroidery and layering and
aging all these different tools worked
really well in this form of black and
white will all great neptune's ocean
wash this blood clean from my hands
it always came to the way i would light
it
we never really know if it's there or
night
and it's really in the play
so what if we play with this idea of not
knowing
or if there is a transition that you can
see going from there tonight
it was a first thing just to be kind of
ambiguous with the light the shadows are
very sharp and i use theater light in
fact i didn't use any movie light it was
the light you use for rock and roll
concert things without all remedy should
be without regard what's done is done
we have scorched the snake not killed it
[Music]
the way the film that joel brilliantly
made that francis
brilliantly played it moves
it really moves you understand what it
is and
he took his time and got it right joel
talked to us about how he wanted to make
macbeth into a film while preserving the
theatrical experience of it so he was
going to use filmic influences mainly
from german expressionism to turn this
into a
film
the format choice that the movie was
shot in 2d backdrops that kind of look
like backdrops in the real theaters and
all the artistic choices that were made
would lead to a little bit of an
abstraction especially in the sequences
where we are not entirely sure what is
reality and what is not
adds to that level of stage performance
so it's a combination of backdrops
painted backings
nets screams and stuff like that
are you a man i
and a bold one that dare look upon that
which might afford the devil an academy
frame was about the power of the
close-up it's a fabulous format and you
know seriously when you have denzel's
face in academy it feels a frame and
it's it's already very strong
and francis is the same
such a presence
being in the academy framing and being
able to be in dialogue and to draw with
joel you could design the sets for those
parameters
it was designed to leave you not in a
real place gravity isn't quite working
right and you're unsettled by this as a
viewer
[Music]
what we're all doing is contributing to
a framed piece of art that joel is
creating
what we were creating with the costumes
were sort of chess pieces all the styles
the costumes and everything were just
solid edges shapes triangular conical
cylinder
and the way people sort of moved around
the set were like chess characters i
based it on things that would be
flattering first to francis mcdormand
and to denzel washington that's one of
the reasons why there's lattice work in
the chest and on the shoulders of the
armor and there's this tufting technique
that we used on the under armour and a
quilting technique that we used in the
sleeves and it's all in an effort to
create interest without being
distracting in close-ups
and then it was about shapes how can i
bring some tension to the image
here's a spot
out i say
but it was uh trying to find a balance
where they have to work together the
lines and the acting and the light are
in sync he kind of gives a very clear
idea of what the lighting is supposed to
be on set
and that kind of dictates also what
we're going to be working with later so
whatever we do needs to fit into his
lighting scheme it was also bruno's idea
which i thought was fantastic let's
start painting the shadows into the sets
all men else i have avoided thee but get
thee back
my soul is too much charged with blood
of line already
francis he's brilliant obviously and
passionate
i love her she's a beast
and so am i so it was a great uh we
wouldn't call it a battle because it was
a concert it's just two forces coming
together i was getting ready to say for
good but not for good for evil but we
did it well
i don't think it gets better than
working with bruno as a dp
what bruno brings to it is just this
incredible cinematic history i mean he's
a walking encyclopedia i had a wonderful
relationship with the cinematographer
because he couldn't beat me to work if
he was there at five i'm like i've been
here two hours i would do those speeches
and soliloquies over and over our
collaboration with bruno was far closer
this time than it was on on the last
movie because he was involved a lot more
in the in the post process it was fun
working with them and they they were
fabulous he would bounce ideas off of us
and ask things that he would like to try
out and see what stuff looks like so it
was a kind of an ongoing process and say
oh why why don't we do this or that alex
and michael uh the east side effects
guys
they have a collaboration with joel and
they've been i think this is like their
third or fourth movie with him
on this movie we started turning stuff
over to them almost immediately
and that really really helped us because
there are so many sequences in the film
where it's kind of a conversation with
the vfx department
we couldn't finish cuts of scenes until
the vfx were kind of at a certain place
and so the vfx had to kind of inform the
edit of certain scenes so we had to kind
of go back and forth with them a lot and
they really made that easy
you remember in the apparition room when
the three witches are talking to him
the cold run is
obviously we didn't have water on set so
the cauldron is totally visual effect
working together with the dp reno del
bonnell was a great experience
for me this time was the first one where
he was actually able to work completely
in a sound stage which he's known for
because he likes to control the lighting
to the nth degree
so here he could really shine and show
us what he's capable of
we tried to do as much in camera as we
could it was not like
bringing multiple cameras and like 3d
things
it was just like no one carrying and
then we sorted out
later in post and i think there ended up
being over like 400 vfx shots which for
a film of this size is a lot
some are very complex the end so crows
and everything is all visual effect
they did an amazing job
the opportunity to work with joel and
francis on this project in particular
was one i couldn't miss
to follow joel and to see how he works
and the level of concentration and
preparation was a sight to see so it was
one of the best experiences i've had
as an
joel surrounded himself with these other
artists that wanted nothing more but to
participate in his creation of this
world
and i think that as an audience member i
hope that you see that i'm really proud
of it i think it's enormously uh
beautiful
i feel like i've done my job well it was
very special the time to worry about
flying is when you're on the ground you
don't trust the pilot don't go
we were flown around by the most
brilliant
pilot
in the business joel cohen
and a brilliant co-pilot frances
mcdormand
so i knew i was in good hands and i felt
free to try
anything
[Music]
you